так противники конституційної реформи
кабінету матео ренці прощається з
прем'єру немає і волосся про свій вигляд
ставку пісня провалу на референдумі
Інтима нам йти стабілізатора буду ряду
повям з простіше не два полотна і складаємося
а парламенту з крученики кістя члену
сина туди урізання їхнього неповного жити
чисто себе три сотки носив не
висовувалася апарати
у team chi ще світку вати ланки влади
у президента італії серджо маттарелла
теоретично в чиїй mh виліз назад world
девід ставку голови у ряду у бутіку
мразі очевидному наступна каринтії
знімаємо ще президент так уже скажи чау
ренте
в італії може відвар це перехідні
ульотних ну гарний до нових парламентських
виборах у 2018 уроки на вимикають також
дасть рукавах виборі вже доступна в уроку
дати йому начхати пройдусь їм провести
лайки знімають результат референдуму як
владно пором
проти воріт італію на політичну то
економічно на стабільного партнера поїсть
без шансів для поліції ситуації
найбільшим годинникам аджі економічно
ситуація пошукайте дубок та політична
ситуація стабілізується все подалі та
смерть спідниці не вкрай реформи зависнувши
палітрі наприклад простіше не на камеру
здутий угу беру критичного апарату
економіста прогнозу і так вже по вул.
було не банківську пацюків ще можна по тих
прийду напам'ять силу економіку вони всередині
вони за зовнішньо інвестори не рожеві
встромити вкладу то простіше в італію до нас
таня кравчук частина iv хочемо cool ці
годинник на стануть і чин залишусь біля завалу
ти шпет харчуванням аджи праві популісти
після любити позиції на відплив витрати
популярності у ряду візерунка стоять плив
правих сил тривожний сигнал для
євросоюзу за владу на мій будь них
планових диво рядкових парламентських
виборах bourget омитися оправок стримати
стали , ніж від його сальвіні
тару ввібрати руку почнемо коміка гриву
стоп знак на noble за всі листя докри
краї на обличчі однак вапух вона для
стабільності е100 us кути в єврозони
Зіко і право публіка хоче вийти